so in the aftermath of the January 6th
Trump riots and the hundreds and
hundreds of arrests and starting to see
uh the processing into the court system
of some of the alleged criminals the
rioters one of the questions that we've
discussed and one of the questions
that's come up is not only what are
these individuals going to be charged
with but what would prosecutors be able
to prove and some of the most serious
charges that could be levied against
some of these individuals would be
charges of sedition and as we said when
we talked about this maybe a month ago
maybe six weeks ago at this point as
some of these cases were starting to be
built was that sedition much like
perjury can be obvious colloquially and
yet very difficult to prove in a court
of law because you do need to be able to
demonstrate Beyond a reasonable doubt
that the mindset of the perpetrator is
knowable and that you can say this was
their intent when they in the case of
perjury said something that was untrue
under uh said something untrue under
oath and meant to overthrow the
government when they were participating
in the Trump riots well it appears as
though
prosecutors at least in some of these
cases believe that they can do that
because there's a new New York Times
report from just the last few hours
which says that quote evidence the
government obtained in the investigation
into the January 6th attack on the
capitol most likely meets the bar
necessary
to charge some of the suspects with
sedition according to Michael Sherwin a
federal prosecutor who's been leading
the Justice Department's inquiry this
was from an interview yesterday the
department has rarely brought charges of
sedition rights the New York Times the
crime of conspiring to overthrow the
government but in an interview with 60
Minutes Sherwin said quote I personally
believe the evidence is trending toward
that and probably meets those elements I
believe the facts do support those
charges
and I think that as we go forward more
facts will support that this is
obviously not going to be the charge for
most of the hundreds of people that are
going to be charged or have been charged
here but it appears as though some will
be and this is Major it's been 11 years
you have to go back to 2010 for the last
time that there was a federal charge of
sedition and that was a charge against a
Michigan militia of plotting to provoke
an armed conflict with the government in
order to overthrow it they were
ultimately acquitted and back then and
this is this goes to mindset the judge
in the Michigan case from 2010
said that the Justice Department Federal
prosecutors did not prove the defendants
were concretely trying to oppose and
overthrow the United States government
so this is going to be I don't want to
say these are landmark cases it seems
hyperbolic but this will be a really big
deal because now we have not only
rioters inspired by Trump not only
rioters inspired by the lies from Trump
and his followers and and others on the
right that Joe Biden stole the election
as the reason that they were doing this
but we may see some of these very very
serious federal charges of uh sedition
and it's going to take some time for all
of this to work through uh the system
and to ultimately see what is there now
I think it's also important in terms of
expectation setting
even if there are charges of sedition
that doesn't necessarily mean you're
going to see trials with guilty not
guilty verdicts deciding on sedition you
could see some of these individuals
rioters charged with sedition initially
but then it never goes to trial and
there's a plea agreement where they
agreed to plead guilty to something
lower and there's no question I mean
listen if you said it's a numbers game
if you see 10 sedition charges I don't
know how many you'll see if you see 10
sedition charges I would imagine that
the vast majority seven eight you never
get a trial on sedition charges and an
eventual not guilty verdict I think most
of them uh you you get they get pled
down and part of the reason would be
I mean listen on both sides based on the
history of Federal sedition charges if
you're the lawyer for one of these
rioters you understand that although it
may not be likely to be found guilty on
sedition it's a very big hill to climb
for the federal prosecutors that if your
client was guilty of sedition it would
be really bad so you may go to them and
say listen it's really in our interests
not to put this uh to trial and you may
have a rioter who's more likely to
accept a plea on some lesser charge if
you're the prosecutors even I mean
listen even if you feel pretty good
about a sedition charge if it's not
bulletproof as far as you're concerned
it's also a risk to you to put that to
trial and possibly get an acquittal and
end up getting nothing against some of
these rioters so it's we may see the
charges the attorney said the prosecutor
says that he believes there's evidence
for it a sedition charge on some of
these cases but I think if you get it
both sides would be well incentivized uh
to plea it to to plead it down and I
wouldn't be at all shocked if very few
or even none of this addition charges
ever actually go to trial where you get
a determination of guilt or lack of
guilt honest Edition charge I could be
wrong we're going to follow it that's
the latest we know as of right now
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15 off a high quality wrist
watch is the perfect way to elevate your
style own at least one watch that makes
you feel great when you put it on you
can often see me wearing my Ventura
watch on the show mine is the gunmetal
vessel model I'm a big fan of the
metallic look of the face of the watch I
like the silicone strap you won't find a
better made watch for this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy and five-year warranty
they'll give you 15 off everything in
their store and free shipping at
davidpackman.com watch use the coupon
code Pacman